we're doomed  something very big  and very dangerous is headed our way  Immortals us is real and it's coming  we are wandering into the literal end of  days as we speak  I think he's serious  project it's the pursuit of immortality  have you ever wondered why you've looked  exactly the same for decades  [Music]  take care of your longevity that's it  it's all over that you love  we have to stop this before it's too  late  what do you saying do you want to go and  save some worlds  we are heroes are we not  ah fine  Code Red  [Music]  stop this we have to confront our past  we're gonna have to go back to where  this all began  [Music]  holy [ __ ] we're doomed at least you got  to have an orgasm before you die  [Music]  thank you